all right the box rowdy rich you have to
play low this giant a broadcasting have
to watch this guy a cappella a sexier
sir good dark lit mom I'm just captain
guess what he said my 4 to 6 p.m. I read
all your comments from Johnny live oh
man yeah all right so just so few of you
listening the context here is the old
man in Jacksonville Florida sitting next
to his karaoke machine and the video
title is the Box rowdy rich so yeah this
old man is about it to the box my rowdy
rich there's a hundred and thirty six
thousand likes yeah why is he doing this
dude you know he just wants to be on you
know he's alive now Johnny D is alive
anyway go go to his livestream you'll
check the live stream oh man all right
we're doing this just real quick I mean
we're at the end anyway
[Music]
I don't all right turn off because we're
gonna get copyrighted is that what that
was I don't know I don't he avoids it
apparently in this video I don't know
that's no oh boy oh boy have you not
seen this no his eyes blue his hell bro
look like Daniel Craig from the bridge
up from the eyelid kind of does I don't
know who anybody kills it
he absolutely rips it 12 are roasted all
the Hawks for the second device
[Music]
my soul all right all right do you see
the you see the Bud Light ads that
posted yeah they're so [__] funny
dude nice man hilarious genius so funny
the spleen thing yeah such a great job
it really is I was more into the
physical comedy of him just like yanked
all over the [__] uh yeah convenience
store that's it so I love how sorry I
was just talking on my spleen yeah hello
you got any pretzels nailed that line I
was chuckling at the Doritos commercial
he did and Sosa's in the back oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh wait real quick
sidebar this [__] is like how the box by
roddy rich was made in seven minutes
it's like no I've watched that fair you
know yeah yes you can make that beat in
seven minutes after other people spent
hours making it I [__] hate when
people say that [__] yo this beat was
made in 30 seconds it wasn't and no no
no I don't think that's what they're
saying no I think they're saying here
here's how it was made I edited this
down edited this now because obviously
they didn't make it in seven minutes
either it's like you can watch it how
it's made in seven minutes
I always interpret those as like it's
like a dislike look how easy this beat
is yeah so I made it in four minutes
yeah yeah or you know it's like the
other do from tik tok how to rap like
the baby in one minute I hate I hate
those videos it's like I [__] hate
those it's like no wrote you can do that
in a minute because another person did
that already multiple times and then you
listening to it a bunch of times yeah
yeah okay this is how they did it yeah
it's like no [__] by the way I know
something always like you could talk
about anything can you talk about that I
farted to my mouth
yeah like nah yeah yeah yeah yeah look
how to sound like de baby in one minute
after ripping his entire cadence
delivery and style of writing yeah by
the way know someone's gonna call you
I'm being like funny how Cody says it's
cool to cringey yourself and then he
[__] look thanks for that old guy and
says what why is he doing that cuz he
wants to yeah yeah you might as well get
ahead of those now all the cops are
gonna be this is Cody and 50 or whatever
hey look it's Cody right now no I just
meant like I just meant yeah I mean I
guess but like it no I just feel like
it's kind of Abner Abner mph or like a
you know eighty year old to be like I'm
gonna do karaoke online I don't I'm not
hating the fact that he wants to do it
and you know it is bro how he shouldn't
be saying Han word I don't know if
that's what he did though okay I don't
know if that's what he did again I
didn't have headphones but I don't know
if that's what he did um I think yeah
he's just one of those innocent like you
know so one of those innocent accounts
dude where he's just oh look he games as
well he's just keeping up with it man
he's just he's just here with us he just
another dude on the Internet damn he
just a lot of these videos yeah
that hat is my boy Gus absolute ice cold
you know bros got a crazy upload
schedule damn quick oh you got you got
bump and grind on there and he does the
sunglasses
he's got rocket League with Elijah Pepe
wow he's playing fortnight with Miss
Helen okay I'm saying our boy our boys
dreams to his dreams man I mean like he
streams games yeah on YouTube so he's
he's with it bro he's with it Johnny
Blaze Helen he just say he's just a user
like the rest of us yeah that's I mean
yeah Who am I to judge addicted to the
Internet all right
you